also important show note I just clogged
the toilet before we went live
backs I was panicking
I was sitting in there and uh it
wouldn't go down the water line is
dangerously High by the way because you
know whenever a clogs one of your hose
you throw up a prayer you say just God
please just whatever sometimes the
pressure sucks it down sometimes you
know there's a divine intervention and
it goes down so I held the thingy down
and then the water comes all the way up
and I'm like okay I gotta stop there's
no plunger in there this was like two
minutes before the show was gonna start
I let's stop everybody in panic the
whole group I said the koi's club don't
know what to do I can't leave this year
but I'm hoping that
um in between now and the end of the
show God will have done his thing to
intervene sometimes it does work that
way you know it really does it really
does and so so I say up a prayer though
whoever the up there